hi you guys must be new to town right
new to town but not new to the country
we just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
[Music]
slides off limits to Ching chongs
cute
do you want to be best friends look at
me look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country we used
to talk about it all the time lower
little remember Grand Adventure to find
your birth mother so proud of you
[Music]
cat lives there now your famous college
roommate you ready to lose to a
celebrity
Dead Eye is coming by the way Deadeye
your cousin hey Audrey oh hi hey
where did that come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in high
Ching okay will you guys come with me
yes I love a grand Adventure
oh hi so nice to see an American what do
you do for work it's the cops are doing
a back check
is it a condom we can't get caught with
drugs in China we'll get jailed for life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
[Music]
we could still find her our passports
are in my suitcase that got stolen you
know we can bypass the airport security
K-pop Stars
everyone remember their names sassy
cutie Lisa Lisa too I don't believe
these girls are sinners girls
show them
um why are we supposed to show you're a
fan of cardi B right yeah but is she
here
there's some in this house
did you get the coke bags out yeah but
only seven and I think I put an eight
just push pull I mean twice
it's my baby
[Music]